[Musique]
on a en février inej exact à la rue ça
arrivait très vite vous avez perdu votre
travail vous avez perdu votre
appartement et bim le tas la rue dans
toute la journée vous êtes senti
harceler les passants pour 2 euros vous
est vide et il faisait froid le sortant
du coup vous appeler le samu social
comme on vous a dit et au bout de trois
quarts d'heure une heure où vous réponds
mais on vous répond pour vous dire que
tous les centres d'hébergement sont
complets
tous les gymnastes sont pleins mais
voilà merci d'avoir essayé retenter
demain bon courage au revoir
clic vous faites quoi ce soir c'est ce
qui est arrivé à des milliers de
personnes en france on estime que la
moitié des appels au 115 sont refusés et
que parmi les gens qui sont à la rue la
moitié en appel même pull 115
du coup toutes nos structures d'accueil
des sans abri en fait elle met à l'abri
uniquement 25% des besoins
un car maintenant imaginez quand une
solution une solution industrielle
économique flexible qu'en puissent
mettre en place maintenant pour toutes
les personnes qui dorment dehors puisse
au moins dormir dormir au chaud
ça c'est la solution que je porte
j'étais en expatriation un an au
monténégro et là bas même dans la
capitale il ya personne qui dort dehors
c'est luce inconcevable donc quand je
suis rentré en france c'était en janvier
2010 est de tracer paris en plein hiver
et ya des mecs qui se met sous des bancs
en mettant des bouts de carton sur le
côté pour s'isoler et des tentes qui
s'effondre sous la neige
combien la neige qui tombe directement
sur les sacs de couchage et ai-je donc
je traverse paris en même temps je me
dis quand un blessés arrivent dans un
hôpital on soigne on cherche pas à
savoir avant si les français s'ils une
carte vitale si c'est un type bien aussi
c'est sa faute s'il est même s'il est
malade il arrive on soigne on tolérait
pas de laisser quelqu'un sur le trottoir
avec une jambe cassée ou en sang en
france on a des personnes qui dorment
par -5 degrés dehors et qu'on refuse des
centres d'hébergement
voilà moi je suis jeune
je suis ingénieur du coup je ne supporte
pas les problèmes sans solution il ya
des gens qui dorment dehors on va déjà
fait en sorte qu'ils aient moins froid
donc l'idée c'était de faire un abri qui
permettent de protéger les personnes
mieux qu'une tante ou un sac de couchage
j'ai fait le premier proto en mai 2017
avec des bouts de carton des boues
d'isolation de maisons du scotch et
raquetteurs donc très simple et c'était
le début de l'été donc j'ai demandé un
ami agriculteur de pouvoir tester chez
lui dans sa chambre froide j'ai passé
plusieurs heures par moins 20 degrés en
pull un lit un bouquin
j'appelais saligue louf j'ai retravaillé
le concept pour les semaines qui ont
suivi et je suis arrivé un abri qui a
pas une dizaine de kilos qui est facile
à monter qui est très isolant qui est
confortable étanche ventilé qui est
résistant au feu et surtout l'avantagent
ce qui permet de gagner entre 15 et 20
degrés par rapport à l'extérieur quand
il fait 0 degrés dehors il fait entre 15
et 20 degrés à l'intérieur
voilà j'étais content de moi mais en
montant il fallait que je teste
directement auprès des usagers
donc j'ai fait une dizaine de prototypes
chez moi que j'ai fait directement sur
ma terrasse et je les ai proposé dans
des squatts en chauffage et en extérieur
à à bordeaux les retours est excellent
et des personnes qui ont passé plusieurs
mois au chaud dedans je me suis dit
c'est bien mais c'est pas suffisant il
faut que j'en fasse plus que je teste
dans une ville différente avec un public
différent
donc j'en ai fait dix de plus grâce à
une crotte funding et on les a envoyés à
paris au bois de vincennes et puis au
sud et là encore on a eu des très bons
retours
on a eut reçu par exemple un sms de
benjamin océane rappelle parce qu'ils
étaient très jeunes aisés les 20 et 21
ans ils étaient au bois de vincennes et
pendant la vague de froid de février
2018 nous envoyer un sms en disant on
est bien installé et on est au chaud et
on attend la neige pour voir tout ça il
faisait moins sept degrés dehors on voit
là j'étais content de moi j'avais fait
un produit qui était bien conçu que
jamais fait en effet 20 je vais tester
presqu'un millier de nuit on continue
avec des sans abri directement
je me disais c'est bien j'ai plus
qu'elle proposait au samu social
ils vont l'adopter c'est plié en route
pour de nouvelles aventures
c'était l'an dernier j'ai 26 ans je peux
encore un peu naïfs et du coup j'appelle
les grandes associations pour leur
proposer
et elle me répondit tu veux mettre ça
dans la rue mais est-ce que tu as
l'autorisation de la mairie
du coup j'appelle la mairie qui me dit
tu sais geoffroy le d'urgence des sans
abri c'est une prérogative de l'état
si tu si on peine à mettre ça en place
en fait on des douanes l'état de ses
responsabilités
du coup on peut pas t'aider donc j'ai
appelé les préfectures qu'ils sont les
organes de l'état et ils m'ont dit non
en hiver on héberge tout le monde les
gens qui sont d'ors le sont par choix
là ça m'a pris six mois pour mon compte
que ça va être plus compliqué que prévu
le milieu extrêmement complexe il ya
beaucoup d'opposition au niveau des
politiques et au niveau monde des
différents organes qui composent la
structure des deux sans abri donc voilà
face à la difficulté moi j'ai jeté
l'épongé
j'ai abandonné pas le pas le projet mais
juste l'idée de l'inclure dans la
structure classique dead
donc je me suis entouré de bénévoles et
partenaires on a monté une association
on a industrialisé l'igloo qui est
maintenant fabriqués à côté de bordeaux
à libourne et grâce à des dons privés et
d'entreprises on a pu en faire 150 cet
hiver qui ont protégés environ 200
personnes
narbonne à paris
bordeaux lille et à calais à mons aussi
en belgique et je lis des dons de river
d'entreprise est particulier parce qu on
défiscalise les dons de particuliers à
hauteur de 66 % et les dons
d'entreprises à hauteur de 60%
bref donc ces dons là nous ont permis de
mettre à l'abri 200 personnes on a aussi
donné les plans à des bénévoles à
l'étranger par exemple en république
tchèque
l'igloo se développe très bien on a fait
80 cet hiver dans toutes les villes du
pays
et ils sont en train de lancer
l'industrialisation aussi pour que dès
l'hiver prochain ont pu se mettre à
l'abri les personnes en europe de l'est
et en europe centrale
voilà donc ça c'est mon histoire à moi
fraîcheur nec traîne en bas je suis né à
pau j'ai choisi une école d'ingénieurs
dans la ville la plus ensoleillée de
france
l'igloo ça casse pas trois pattes à un
canard c'est trois bouts de mousse
collés ensemble et d'ailleurs depuis que
j'ai mis en place j'ai reçu des dizaines
de coups de fil de gens qui m'ont dit
qu'ils avaient eu la même idée que moi
et je suis convaincu que si je n'avais
pas mis en place cet hiver il aurait
forcément énergie que ce soit dans un an
ou deux portée par quelqu'un d'autre
mais à l'époque où je vais lancer ben
j'ai regardé à gauche et à droite il y
avait personne de mieux placé que moi
pour le faire du coup bah je les fais
est là où je veux en venir c'est que je
suis convaincu que vous avez tous au
moins une idée ou un antidote pour la
société ou juste pour les gens autour de
vous effectivement si c'est une bonne
idée c'est un bon concept il va
forcément énergie que ce soit vous qui
mettez en place maintenant ou quelqu'un
d'autre plus tard
la différence c'est que si vous ne
mettez pas en place maintenant en fait
vous priver la société des bénéfices
pendant tout le temps que quelqu'un
d'autre prendra pour cher à votre place
et ça
c'est une sacrée responsabilité dans la
vie
le monde se divise en deux catégories
ceux qu'il faut attendre la société et
ceux qui creusent leurs idées vous vous
creusez merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]